[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei den damen und
herren in seiner neuen ausgabe von für
die nach der dauer meinung show im
deutschen fernsehen wir sprechen jetzt
über alkohol karl lauterbach die
steigenden energiepreise und erfahren ob
es zu einem vergehen haben kräne kommen
wird ich verspreche ihnen lassen sich
den nächsten 55 minuten keine einzige
minute langweilen werden meine
großartigen gäste heute abend sind die
pavés ko vorsitz der linksfraktion im
deutschen bundestag
neben ihm frank bauernfeind sie sich
chefin des studentenverbandes ring
christlich demokratischer studenten an
meiner seite bild kolumnist alexander
von schönburg und last but not least
unser stammgast journalist kolumnist
hans ulrich jörges mein name ist nena
stinkt und ich freue mich heute abend
mit meinen aufreger des tages starten zu
dürfen unsere regierung ist ein
freiheitsfalken werde die dänische
regierung gegen die krone panikmache
kämpft spricht unsere regierung von
basis schutzmaßnahmen am 20 märz ein
crooner maßnahmen fallen aber es könnte
das ist noch nicht beschlossen einen
kroner basisschutz geben ich werde schon
wütend wenn ich nur das wort höre
basismaßnahmen was soll das bedeuten
nennen wir die maßnahmen jetzt
basismaßnahmen bei jede basis für
weitere maßnahmen fehlt auf welcher
basis möchte die politik und so
grundrechte weiter einschränken es
reicht wir brauchen keine basis
maßnahmen sollen den vielen fällen
ja da muss ich sagen ich stimme dir der
these vollkommen zu und habe dafür zwei
erklärungen zum einen sagen neue
umfragen dass ungefähr zwei drittel der
deutschen nach wie vor an ihrer masken
pflicht festhalten wollen weil sie sonst
total sich als wahrscheinlich allein
gelassen fühlen und
freiheit hat in diesem land keiner
richtig große lobby mehr die freiheit
ist eine minderheit und die mehrheit
sucht den starken staat nach wie vor und
der staat wiederum das ist die andere
seite will uns nicht loslassen er hat
sich daran gewöhnt die politik die
regierung dass sie über jahre hinweg den
leuten gesagt was sie zu tun und zu
lassen haben und das war so angenehm das
lässt man so bald nicht los und man
bereitet sich im kopf auch schon darauf
vor dass man von der masken pflicht im
herbst nächsten herbst wenn es wieder
losgeht mit einem neuen virus dann
gleich wieder vollgas gibt und wieder
die anderen sachen drauf legt
ichwieder das an ich habe mir schon
überlegt aber ich bin noch nicht so weit
ob ich das in zivilem ungehorsam einfach
verweigere und mal ausprobieren wenn ich
ohne masken ein supermarkt eingehen was
dann passiert ich habe jedenfalls keine
lust mehr ich bin brillenträger im
winter hast du ständig eine beschlagene
brille wenn du ein brötchen kauft und
mir reicht es jetzt und das leute so
verängstigt sind dass sie sich ohne
maske gar nicht mehr bewegen wollen das
ist mir so was von fremd also tut mir
leid ich bin sowieso hat mich stark
entfremdet von den deutschen muss ich
sagen aber es kann doch sein dass
basismaßnahmen nicht unbedingt die
pflicht zu masken tragen kann sich ja ja
es ist eine möglichkeit aber kann das
nicht so sein dass man da
wissenschaftsbasierte entscheiden sollte
was real passiert wenn wir wirklich eine
situation bekommen ich will niemand weiß
wie eine eventuelle virus variante
aussieht ich bin total für lacko ich bin
auch gegen die meisten gar keine frage
wie die möglichst schnell loswerden aber
es kann ja wirklich passieren dass wir
wieder eine zugespitzte lage haben und
dass leute die sich auskennen sagen die
maske schutz vor infektionen ist ich
will das nicht ausschließen und deswegen
finde ich die grundidee und ich muss
wirklich die regierung nicht verteidigen
zu sagen wir haben einen
instrumentenkasten aber das grundprinzip
das sei der kern
die rechte des grundgesetzes die gelten
punkt aus ende und dann kann man unter
besonderen bedingungen einschränkt dass
das ist ja ins verdrehen gekommen es
gibt jetzt eine situation dass das genau
nie mehr passiert gibt es ja gibt's denn
unveränderte bedingungen die gibt es
noch nicht also wir lassen alles nach
bloss das nicht und da muss ich sagen
dass es da ist das stimmig ist das ist
nicht wahr sein muss muss noch nicht was
ist das für ein land wo die regierung
den bürgern nicht sagen kann ihr
entscheidet jetzt selbst eher andere
ihre masken tragt eintrag sie wenn ihr
wollt das kann ja auch eine empfehlung
sein fragt sie in der innen öffnen
verkehrsmitteln trat sie im supermarkt
ab wie ihr müsst nicht und das ist doch
ganz sicher dass die meisten leute eine
maske dort tragen werden ich nicht aber
die meisten schon aber wenn der
supermarkt rappelvoll wäre würde ich
vielleicht auch wieder einer auf setzte
aber jedenfalls nicht vorgeschrieben wie
sowie so wurden denn schon lange vor der
partie in bestimmten arbeitsgebiet
masken getragen einfach völlig normal
war niemand würde bei einer op keine
maske tragen ist doch völlig normal so
und so sage ich basismaßnahmen heißt
doch nicht dass das alles bestehen
bleibt ich wünsche mir dass möglichst
nichts bestehen bleibt aber zu sagen wir
haben jetzt wirklich einen
instrumentenkasten nun ganz positiven
sinne das finde ich nicht so frauen
schaffen es in andere länder als schweiz
zum beispiel erst jetzt auch die
maßnahmen alle fallen seit gehört in
england hat es gemacht schweden ist ganz
anders durch die panini gekommen als wir
muss man nicht langsam auch mal sagen
zurück mit unserer freiheit ich meine
virus ist ja nicht in deutschland so
sehr anders als zum beispiel in england
und anderen ländern in england war ich
zum beispiel das war ein tolles
wochenende ich hab die maske nicht
einmal getragen aber wissen sie was ich
so toll fand erwartet das verständnis
füreinander entstand im supermarkt
mancher hat maske auf manche nicht und
das meine ich damit und bei dieser basis
maßnahme könnte es wirklich sein dass
die maske weiterhin verpflichten bleibt
zb innenräume und das muss ich wirklich
sagen darf eigentlich mit blick auf die
aktuelle hausbesuche und ich bin auch
gerade junge leute die vielleicht 14 15
sind in der schule sind und jetzt mit
basismaßnahmen
aufwachsen und weiter wachsen und immer
ihre maske in der tasche zu haben das
finde ich hat nichts mit einem jungen
gefühl zu tun und ich finde das hat mehr
damit zu tun angst zu verbreiten eben
nicht den respekt oder oder das
verständnis füreinander zu haben sondern
finde ich spaltet unsere gesetze ich
kann überhaupt wenn ich das mal
dazwischen werden darf ich kann den
begriff maßnahmen die ich kann das ist
ein spezial begriff des hässlichen start
der maßnahmen ergreift gegen seine
bürger der dies und jenes vorstadt
maßnahmen ist eigentlich in einem nach
meinem gefühl von der sprache her in
einem demokratischen liberalen staat
nicht mehr möglich das substantiv
maßnahme muss man nicht wählen man kann
auch regeln nennen ja wir haben wir
hatten mal wieder doch wir haben nur
sehr sehr viele regeln in deutschland
haben sowohl gesetz bücher und hier
finde ich sollte man regularien
aufstellen die möglich sind und die
angewendet werden können und ich bin ja
immer ein vertreter gewesen der gesagt
hat ich liebe leute lasst uns nicht das
für alle gleich machen sondern wirklich
in besonderen situationen
ich habe ein beispiel gesagt wo niemand
etwas dagegen hat bei jeder op wird eine
maske gefragt das war schon früher so ja
und da würde niemand sagen maske ist
quatsch so und so sage ich auch zum
beispiel in altenheimen kann es sein
dass es sinnvoll ist weil die leute ihn
so gefährdet sind dass man sagt okay
hier müssen diejenigen die dort arbeiten
eine maske tragen ich sehe ja am
beispiel bei kindern ganz anders war da
nicht die in erster zweiter klasse sind
das eine ganz andere situation
aber wenn eine pandemie wieder
gefährlich werden soll das ist ja jetzt
nicht das ist doch das entscheidende
problem das was bei delta war ist bei
omikron nicht mehr da dann wird
teilweise etwas erzählt was eben nicht
mehr der wahl der worte stimmen kommen
die basismaßnahmen damit die leute haben
liegt vorhaben sei denn dass sie kommen
wird gesagt wir haben inzwischen reisen
kassen und ob da irgendetwas angewendet
wird wir haben doch bei vielen anderen
dingen auch die möglichkeit
rechtsstaatlich zu agieren und machen
ist nicht aus gutem grund nannte denn
die linke bei einer solchen abstimmung
dagegen stimmen unter welchen
bedingungen oder nur die fdp
die fdp wird ja gerade nicht dagegen
stellen aber normalerweise glaube ich
dass alles tapfer mittragen weil das
wird ja im bundestag jetzt behandelt
sehr sicher ich finde naja das für mich
ist entscheidend wie würde ich ihnen das
nicht mehr wie wird das überhaupt
ausgestaltet dass doch die frage ist es
so wie hier teilweise vermutet dass dann
diese maßnahmen gelten oder ist es so
dass ist die möglichkeit besteht unter
bestimmten bedingungen waren danach
bestimmt wirklich gut ich möchte es
wirklich verstörend weil es nicht so
wütend macht als bürgerin ich möchte es
wirklich verstehen auf welcher grundlage
dürfte der staat jetzt überhaupt wir
können auf die hospitalisierung blicken
wir können die inzidenz werte
vergleichen in der schweiz sind sie
höher als in deutschland auf ein auch
die masse also auf welcher grundlage
auch wenn man sich die ganze panini
anschaut und gerade auf welcher
grundlage darf der staat wenn die basis
schutzmaßnahmen jetzt beschlossenen noch
über mich bestimmen ob ich zum beispiel
die maske tragen oder nicht mit wie
viele menschen ich mich treffe ich
verstehe es nicht mehr na ja also das
finde ich zum beispiel die
hospitalisierung rate und wenn denn die
intensivbetten ich sage mal zu 80
prozent belegt werden sind sie ja nicht
deshalb die wirklich die geschichte die
einfach nicht stimmt zehn prozent sind
jetzt mit komapatienten belegt von den
intensivbetten wenn das aber richtig
hoch gehen sollte und wir in die
situation kommen dass wir nicht mehr
bewältigen können dann ist die
möglichkeit auch
massnahmen klassenerhalt nicht markt so
eben daran gibt es aber eine basis
regeln mehr sage ich jetzt mal sondern
ganz ganz andere härte was machen wir
jetzt so richtig schneit was machen wir
denn ich bin so richtig schneien dann
rollen die sogenannten basis maßnahmen
sollen doch jetzt den staat und die in
angst und schrecken versetzten über den
sommer hinweg tragen bis der herbst
kommt für das damit wir uns nicht
entwöhnen in freiheit ist das einzige
land wo zum beispiel niemals die maske
gefallen das macht mich übrigens
besonders wütend abgelegt in anderen
ländern ob in holland oder in österreich
mal wenigstens ein bisschen frei zu
haben im sommer davon wir haben einfach
alles glas nicht dass das das sehe ich
ja als film ein großes problem dass man
eben wirklich in der natur wirklich nur
maske tragen soll das ist einigermaßen
ab sodass teile ist man auch im
innenraum durch
für mich spielen da wie generell in der
pandemie diejenigen die wirklich die
verlierer sind sind häufig kinder und
jugendlichen insbesondere kinder und da
finde ich es viel zu wenig gemacht
das ist nicht meine ich dass kann ich
sowieso voll zu verteidigen also wie der
begriff heißt es mir ehrlich gesagt
wurscht mir geht es darum ein regularium
zu haben wenn es wirklich zu
pandemischen neuen spitzen kommt dass
man agieren kann das ist das war das
jedoch sofort das parlament innerhalb
von paul haben alles möglich
wir müssen jetzt gleich in den alex
etwas mehr bedenken mit der zeit aber
gehofft jetzt erst mal deine these
vorher also meine these dreht sich um
karl lauterbach ich bin fertig mit karl
lauterbach das ist auch nicht mehr etwa
karl lauterbach hat
versagt jetzt als minister im amt ich
will nur an einen punkt erinnern
quasi unter seinen händen ist
es die impfkampagne verschiedenen
gestorben da ist nichts mehr von übrig
hat nichts dafür getan völlig schief
gegangen und hat ein problem mit der
wahrheit das will ich erläutern im
januar das erinnern wir alle gut ist ja
die der genesenen status ganz
überraschend halbiert worden auf drei
monate die leute waren entsetzt wie bei
vielen leuten war es ein schwerer
eingriff in ihr leben und
dafür haften musste bislang nur das rk
ii und dessen präsident lothar wieler
team waren schuld und zwar ganz alleine
wenn man sich ein bisschen punkt tut und
konkreter recherchiert stellt man aber
fest am 14 januar hat das rk ii diese
anweisung auf seiner homepage
veröffentlicht am 15 januar trat sie in
kraft aber am 13 januar einen tag vorher
schon erschien sabine dittmar das ist
die parlamentarische staatssekretärin
von karl lauterbach im bundestag und
kündigte diese diesen abbau des
gemessenen status an sie war die erste
überhaupt das rkw kann erst hinterher
als würde das rk ii sozusagen die
technischen einzelheiten verkünden aber
sie war die erste ich will dass genau
zitieren was sie da gesagt hat der
genesenen status wird künftig nach den
mund nach nach drei monaten bzw 90 tagen
entfallen wörtliches zitat aus einer
kleinen rede sie war so stolz drauf dass
ich diese rede vor homepage bis heute
anbietet
der bundestags vizepräsident wolfgang
kubicki der die sitzung geleitet hat hat
mir berichtet den meisten abgeordnete
gar nicht aufgefallen was sie da gehört
haben das passiert ja manchmal das haus
zur vorbei jedenfalls hat karl
lauterbach die gelegenheit ergriffen und
bis heute in allen möglichen interviews
erzählt dass er nichts davon gewusst
habe ich gebe ihnen auch wieder wörtlich
zitiert aus einem faz interview
da hat er nämlich gesagt dass der
genesenen status über nacht auf drei
monate verkürzt wurde davon war ich
nicht unterrichtet ich nenne diesen satz
einen flirt mit der lüge denn wer das
sage ich nur aus juristischen gründen so
freundlich ich würde sonst hertha
ausdrücken denn man kann annehmen dass
eine staatssekretärin ins parlament geht
um diese botschaft zu überbringen und
der minister weiß nichts davon da muss
man sich ja die haare mit dem fischmarkt
am ende das zu glauben niemals außerdem
ist karl lauterbach bekannt als einer
der im ministerium alles an sich zieht
der nichts an sich vorbeilaufen lässt
und eine parlamentarische
staatssekretärin hat ausdrücklich die
aufgabe den minister nach außen zu
vertreten
er wusste nichts ich glaube kein wort
und nach diesem seifigen dementi erleben
wir auch noch eine
weitere regierungspraxis eine
amtsführung er hat nämlich sofort jetzt
dem rk ii die vollmacht entzogen über
diese frage zu entscheiden er will
selbst entscheiden nach dem motto haltet
den dieb da macht allerdings die union
im bundestag nicht mehr mit denn die
haben begriffen dass man diesem mann
nicht vertrauen darf das haben sie auch
sofort öffentlich erklärt und sie
bestehen darauf dass der bundesrat
künftig an diesen unter unter
entscheidung beteiligt wird stoppen
es wird ja also die der bundesrat ist
ihm schon in arm gefallen nun wird es ja
noch wird die
die die die den genesenen spanne ist ja
inzwischen klammheimlich ohne dass das
viel drüber geredet wieder auf sechs
monate erweitert wurde aber nur für die
geimpften die ungeimpften bleiben weiter
auf drei monaten sitzen wir haben also
eine gespalten der geschichte und das
ist natürlich der höhepunkt wobei die
dreimonatigen ungeimpften das gar nicht
in ihre in ihrer zertifikat eintragen
lassen können apothekers gar nicht
vorgesehen ist es hat ein europäisches
muster dass sie drei monate gar nicht
vor so dass wir jährlich
nein ich mir auf meine konzerte
auskommen ich lasse mich in dieser
freien sendung auch nicht
wir haben
daher erst jetzt das wahre chaos und
verantwortlich ist karl lauterbach
deshalb sage ich
ich will karl lauterbach
nicht mehr erleben wenn im herbst eine
neue ein neues virus über uns kommt dann
ich will auch nach dem freedom day am 20
märz von karl lauterbach befreit werden
der der gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach ist gescheitert er ist
einfach nicht ministrabel dafür noch
sagen so jetzt
ich stimme einem völlig zu dass karl
lauterbach einen sprung ins ministerium
nicht geschafft h er war die ganze zeit
ein großer hoffnungsträger und es gab
einen riesigen druck auch auf olaf
scholz dass der mann minister werden
muss und es gibt in deutschland daher so
ein gewisses vorurteil man muss
möglichst vom fach sein und minister
sein zu können also am besten general
wird verteidigungsminister ist jetzt
auch ein bisschen anders und karl
lauterbach hat diesen sprung nicht
geschafft und was mich wirklich auch
stört deswegen stimmig dazu dass der
wlan oder schuldige ist erstmal völlig
egal was ich von ihm will erhaltet ist
völlig unwichtig aber es ist nun mal so
wenn man minister ist wenn man irgendwo
chef ist muss man sich vor seine leute
stellen und maniche muss man sie
rausschmeißen ja und das hat er nicht
gemacht und das geht nicht dieses
lavieren da stimme ich völlig zu das
geht überhaupt nicht die hoffnung die in
ihn gesetzt worden sind nach hin sparen
sondern mal ganz nebenbei das war eine
große koalition und lauterbach und
sparen waren sehr eng und der war
ständiger ratgeber war ständig auch im
ministerium eigentlich gab es diesen
bruch nicht er wollte was anderes
darstellen uns daran meines erachtens
wirklich bisher nicht gut gefahren ich
finde ja dass ein bisschen schnell dass
jemand nach drei monaten gehen soll mich
ist ja erledigt er an
nur darauf hinweisen er ist ein moment
der beliebteste politiker deutschlands
seinen
eigentlich das müsste eigentlich
macht das müsste mir später machten
pflicht
ist lauterbach hauptverantwortlich dafür
dass wir einen fürchterlichen
mentalitätswandel in diesen in diesen
die diesen zwei jahren hinter uns haben
nämlich zu einem obrigkeitsstaat und zu
einem regieren aber die angst und ich
muss sagen wer mich etwas beunruhigt ist
es nicht dass masken tragen im in
innenräumen ich bin ich bin ich bin
konnte sich ein vorsichtiger mensch ich
habe schon sagrotan benutzer wusstet ihr
alle da kann ich das buch stabil bilden
fiel kurz mittel hatte daran domestos
gedacht ich war schon immer vorsichtig
aber ich lasse mir nicht meine eigene
vernunft nehmen und lasse mich und ich
entscheide selber wo ich vorsichtig bin
und wo ich bin einer frischen luft schon
von polizisten in bayern aufgabe
aufgefordert worden eine maske zu tragen
haben dadurch angezogen und dann sofort
wieder abgelegene weil ich zwei schritte
weiter gehen ich mache ich möchte ich
finde es höchst beunruhigend dass ein
mann der hauptverantwortlich dafür ist
dass wir über angst regiert worden sind
sind dass der plötzlich der beliebteste
politiker sich machen wir haben stimme
ich hier stehe ich mache mir große
sorgen über den mentalitätswandel in
diesen in diesem land ich glaube wir
haben was wir jetzt erlebt haben ist ein
glimpflich davongekommen mit diesen
sicher tückischen virus ich bin
überzeugt dass es werden schlimmere
krankheiten auch auf uns zukommen in
zukunft aber wir haben die generalprobe
als demokratische gesellschaft nicht
bestanden und das ist für mich nicht
eine frage der was gesondert sondern
sondern die aufteilung zwischen
geimpften und ungeimpften das wird
menschen zweiter klasse hätte ich nie
geglaubt dass wir so etwas geben
und das gleiche gilt wenn ich auch für
die regelung mit chance und schossen das
hatten wir jetzt gar nicht gesprochen
also genießen den status ist das eine
aber auch dass johnson & johnson und mit
einer impfung da hat man die
auffrischungsimpfungen dann gemacht
vielleicht freiwillig weil man sich
gesagt hat mag sollte ich mal lieber
machen und auf einmal gilt der status
nicht mehr stimmt und man muss sich
erholen obwohl es eben noch vor einem
halben jahr hieß johnson & johnson ist
sicher sehr richtig es gibt ein es gibt
einen schleichenden wechsel zum
autoritären dafür steht auch karl
lauterbach darum hat er die vollmachten
an das rk ii und das an das
paul-ehrlich-institut
abgegeben weil er vermeiden wollte seine
pläne in der koalition mit der fdp
streitig zu diskutieren die hätte ihm
bei manchem in den wehren in den arm
gefallen oder im bundesrat mit der cdu
also wird das ganze als
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
ausgegeben und wissenschaftler
entscheiden darüber wie wir leben was
ist denn dann übrig von der demokratie
und also politisch las man das als lob
gescheitert gottlos ist ja so dass
wissenschaft schon rolle spielen soll
aber im grundlagenbereich entscheiden
jahren wir ich finde allerdings für mich
mit das größte problem bei karl
lauterbach ist bis zum wahltag hat in
deutschland ungefähr jeder gesagt es
wird keine impfpflicht geben noch vor
olaf scholz war karl lauterbach der
gesagt hat im pflicht und das ist für
einen gesundheitsminister entweder ich
sage die regierung setzt das durch will
das durchsetzen weil sie den
entsprechenden gesetzentwurf oder ich
sage aus der mitte des parlaments dann
allerdings halte ich mich zurück ich
meine dritte olaf scholz und ähnlicher
weise zu aber für karl lauterbach noch
mehr denn erst gesundheitsminister und
hat damit natürlich ein seine autorität
eingesetzt je her zweifellos hat er ist
ja medizinisch vermutlich bewanderte als
wir alle aber die darf man eben nicht so
einsetzen für sony amazon ja nicht wenn
es um eine gewissensentscheidung gibt
das ist das ist wirklich ein großes
problem es wird immer gesagt ist eine
gewissensentscheidung und dann darf man
nicht von dieser position sagen ich bin
für die impfpflicht und jetzt muss es
auch durchgesetzt werden weil es geht um
den gesundheitsminister um den kanzler
es geht ums ganze und das macht
natürlich eine solche entscheidung
unendlich schwierig ich kann die leute
verstehen die für eine impfpflicht sind
ich bin dagegen das ist aber jetzt kann
man diskutieren da soll man einen freien
austausch der freie entscheidung zu
lassen und das ist durch ihn behindert
worden und das finde ich nicht zulässig
wenn man zu machen und geben abzufragen
herr bauernfeind uns auch ein thema
mitgebracht was sich bewegt richtig die
junge generation muss auf die politische
agenda wir haben mittlerweile als
studenten vier semester hinter uns was
das bedeutet ist vor allem
planungsunsicherheit
wir wissen nicht ob wir in der nächsten
woche die vorlesungen und seminare
digital haben analog oder asynchron
was mit dem verein semester regelungen
vor allem im jura studium ist und wie
prüfungen stattfinden ob sie nachgeholt
werden können oder studenten auf das
kommende jahr vertröstet werden dazu
kommt und das ist ehrlich gesagt sehr
schlimm das thema einsamkeit unter
studenten wir haben mittlerweile lange
warteschlangen für psychosoziale
beratungen wir haben die situation dass
studenten wenn sie allein in ihren
ständen zimmern lernen zunehmend
vereinsamen nicht mit ihren kommilitonen
in die mensa gehen können oder zusammen
in der bibliothek lernen können im
gestrigen beschluss der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz finden
wieder mal hochschulen und studenten
nicht den eingang in die
beschlussvorlage
stattdessen werden klar eröffnungs
perspektiven für clubs diskotheken
großveranstaltungen inklusive
sportveranstaltungen klar definiert wie
da ein freedom day aussehen kann
deswegen fordere ich die studenten und
junge generation muss endlich auf die
politische agenda der politik nach
nunmehr zwei jahren und wir brauchen
einen wichtigen tag stichtag für den
freedom day für studenten und junge
leute frankreich gibt die
hundertprozentig recht ich glaube ihr
habt keine lobby weil er als
privilegiert geld das ist jetzt kein
scherz menschen haben das gefühl auch
wenn ich über die probleme in schwester
ist auch studentin
betriebswirtschaftslehre besteht ist
gerade ihren bachelor obwohl sie dieses
beschissene rom studium hatte er hat
sich großartig gemeistert aber ihr habt
keine lobby weil viele euch als
privilegiert empfinden und das ist
falsch weil viele sich das studium
finanzieren müssen sie müssen arbeiten
geht weiß was im schlimmsten finde ich
kriege andauernd im moment leserbriefen
von studenten die gar nicht mehr
studieren dürfen wegen der einrichtungs
bezogenen impfpflicht und das finde ich
fast noch schlimmer neben eh schon den
letzten vier semestern die furchtbar für
euch alle warten ich hätte mein studium
gar nicht durchgezogen kann ich hier und
heute sagen ich brauchte die enge
betreuung mitunter ist so ich muss das
noch mal erklärt programm manchmal la
lecture und deswegen finde ich es ganz
schlimm es werden der lebensträume
genommen entweder durch die einrichtungs
beziehungen pflicht oder weil schon denn
auch einfach aufgeben ich hätte das auch
nicht in rom auf das geschaffte niemals
und deswegen das unfassbar wichtiges
thema mitgebracht und das wesentlich an
eine universität einem universitäts lärm
ist ja der ok austausch sowie betty die
diebe rückt ist den universitäten der
welt sind universitätsstädte heidel
nicht nur die optik aktuelle
absolut aber manchmal ergänzt sich das
ja auch aber man sich man kann sich auch
in der geist verlieren
was mich am meisten wundert es ist
glaube ich nicht angekommen und
studenten sind mittlerweile knapp drei
millionen in deutschland 82 millionen
ist das nicht mehr wie vielleicht vor 40
jahren eine mini minderheit das ist eine
status gruppe die so nicht stattfindet
ich habe dazu nur zwei sachen
beizutragen das absurdeste was ich
gelesen habe kommt von der uni
greifswald wo die universitätsleitung
den studenten vollbärte untersagt hat
die müssen sie ab da bin ich auch da
damit die f2 maske passt und sich eng
anliegt das ist ja wirklich der hammer
schlechthin aber voll war es sollten
trotzdem du hast die freiheit das ist
wahrheit wirklich wie müssen sich
rasieren oben dürfen sie stehen lassen
da passt die maske der un-mission ganzen
lassen der kombi während hervorgekrochen
ich bin ganz sicher faktencheck
ganz einfach internet zu finden zweitens
anfrage man die studierenden müssen sich
wehren dass wir müssen auf sich
aufmerksam
wer einfach zu hause sitzt und wo sie
hin studiert der fällt nicht weiter auf
von den kultusministern ist nichts zu
erwarten auch von den
universitätsleitungen nicht ihr müsst
auf der straße sein vielleicht solltet
ihr euch das ist ja jetzt sehr in mode
sind lokal wie blut ja wo festkleben
also vorhanden so sagen arbeitsleben
wurde einfahrt des kanzleramts fest
leben wenn herr mack und zu besuch kommt
so dass der also dort 20 minuten warten
muss bis er wieder gelöst
komponente
wenn ich eine kleine bemerkung machen
ich teile das aber was mich noch viel
mehr stört sind die noch kleineren weil
die haben noch weniger einnahmen und die
schülerinnen und schüler die in den
kitas na und die dann betroffenen eltern
die sind wirklich die verlierer gab an
die mini studenten haben ja wirklich die
chance sich zu wehren und machen das ja
auch ein bisschen dass die noch weniger
lobby haben sehe ich nicht so also
allein schon die berichte in zeitungen
antwort nein die kinder und das machen
wir ja aber ich finde es auch richtig
und haben auch viel berichtet die
studenten sind für mich auch eigentlich
auch große vermieter haltepunkt ist
richtung und schauen schauen sie mal
langsam wie bei der einander auf
gegenwehr nicht gegen haider umfeld nur
ergänzen ich will dass williams ich
finde es zum 1 corona beschluss von
gestern steht drinnen jahr die schüler
und studenten wissen wir also wir
solidarisieren uns mit denen die haben
also da probleme wir sehen die
einsamkeit etc mehr nicht was soll es
also was hat so
einen satz im beschluss von der mpk zu
suchen anstatt das mal zu diskutieren
breit und außen punkt 1.2 ist
könnte man nachvollziehen aber es ist
tatsächlich so dass man eben davon
ausgeht studenten sind erwachsene ist
ein junge erwachsene leute die können
sich organisieren die können
da quasi klare standpunkte setzen
aufwiegelt und das ist eben glaube ich
das hauptproblem man gehe davon aus das
sind junge erwachsene
sie können das schon selbst nicht machen
wenn man aber jetzt im zweiten oder
dritten semester studiert woher wissen
sie wie ihre kommilitonen sind woher
wissen sie wie ihr campus von innen
ausschaut und das ist wirklich der
kernpunkt deswegen ich auch heute hier
bin um das thema mitgebracht habe weil
ich glaube aber er ist es nicht gewohnt
schwimmverband hat ist ja nicht auch
wirklich so leider dass viele der
student oder wie man wie man heute
modernen sagen müsste studierenden
reicht
studenten strich studierende unterstrich
kern steht die iren dass die meisten
dieser wir sind offenbar
mentalitätswandel und diese
obrigkeitshörigkeit für dich vorher
angesprochen voll unterstützen ich und
sage ich ich ich bewege mich eine ich
gelegentlich ähnlich wie herr jörges
nach einer studentin
generation die das was der staat
vorschreibt schrecklich findet ich wenn
ich junge leute sehe die finden das alle
toll die finden womöglich auch
lauterbach toll wo ist denn euer
revolutionärer geistigen wo ist denn der
geist in europa
weil da ist der hält an geißler
nein also das ist endlich wurde sogar
jörges mit dem und ich wollten ja wenn
ein geräusch vor dem kanzler an clips
lebe ich mich mit aber unter mit räubern
soll bade angemessen es gibt ja nicht
nur omas gegen rechts dann gibt es
europas für studenten
die studenten haben sich sehr
solidarisch verhalten ja wie waren die
gruppe die auch wussten wir sind junge
erwachsene ich sage lieber nichts
natürlich erst die älteren und schwachen
und auch wichtig die schule in die
kleinsten usw nur und und das war bis zu
einem bestimmten zeitpunkt auch okay ja
wo ich auch sagt gut wir sind am anfang
der pandemie wir verhalten uns jetzt
erstmal solidarisch wir sind jetzt ruhig
schon falsche wort aber gut ist also das
quasi war nicht meine meinung also im
schongang und
dann aber dass trotz dessen nach
eineinhalb jahren oder nach zwei jahren
jetzt nichts mehr passiert ist also
quasi wir so in vergessenheit geraten
sind und vielleicht auch noch nie auf
der agenda aber unwahrscheinlich da
mache ich nicht mehr mit wie für mich
entscheidende frage ist wie reflektieren
sie denn als studierende das war es in
den letzten zwei jahren erlebt haben was
was schafft das für eine studentin
generation mit welchem bewusstsein kommt
die jetzt hier raus was lässt sie sich
nicht mehr gefallen was lässt sie sich
gefallen welche schlussfolgerung zieht
sie aus dem allen wenn ihr euch
natürlich nicht unterhalten könnte ich
gar nicht seht ist das schon mal
schwierig aber sie jetzt als person
gefragt was ist ihre haltung nach zwei
jahren wir müssen uns da wir müssen uns
da vereinen und die politik auffordern
und das ist halt das nächste
hochschulpolitik ist immer ein
landesthema also vor allem an die
landesregierungen herantreten unter
druck machen dass so ein flickenteppich
den wir während corona an den
hochschulen teilweise unterscheidet
sicher dass zu fachbereichen und
dozenten ob man digital oder im präsenz
meine erreichen anteil kaum jemand
seminar studiert hat das waren elf
studenten was ich hinterher weil die
noten dann mit matrikelnummer quasi
versendet wurden das waren elf an der
zahl ich wusste nicht wer ein halbes
jahr den gleichen kurs mit mir hatte
konnte mich nicht austauschen nicht mal
über ich sag mal datenschutzkonforme
chat prozess gibt es alles das gibt es
auch unsere dem her aber wenn der
professor das nicht anlegt weil ihm das
egal ist er sechs videos hochwertig mir
die videos alles stunden lang fragen
nicht beantwortet werden dann ist das
ein riesenproblem und dann deswegen mein
letzter punkt auch professoren dozenten
und die hochschulen sind in der
verantwortung nicht nur die politik aber
vor allem die da uns studenten
wahrzunehmen ich sehe meine
schlussfolgerung der den erzählt er ist
ja früheren wahl für organisationen ist
das jetzt anders geworden das muss jetzt
ein
wir haben jetzt eine mini unterbrechen
wir sind gleich direkt wieder zurück und
dann funktioniert ja auch das
zeitmanagement besser bis gleich
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
brauchen und nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren siegte nach acht geben trotz der
schlagzeilen machen mein name ist
relativ
so nicht
herr jörges retten
aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der damen führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und um die füße ruhen die ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur der
afg zu überlassen lasst den leuten noch
mal den spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu führen
und sie sollen den doch auch wichtig
sein das können eines konnte zum manko
bleibt einmal kurz an das auto immer
noch das unmögliche andrack träger aus
in bewegung bringen ich habe meinen
beifall um eine sache immer bekommt wer
kümmert sich darum niemand ist
man muss das ganz kleine auch darüber
sprechen ganz einfach nicht wer sich
richtig ist ich konnte mädchen nicht
mehr glauben nur noch vier wochen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und bevor wir zu den
letzten beiden spannenden themen
vorankommen wollen wir einmal zu meinem
kollegen dem auch der moderator von
filmnacht aber vor allem auch dem bild
vize schalten paul ronzheimer er ist in
der ukraine hat wird schon den ganzen
tag mit dem ukrainischen präsidenten
verbracht waren der front toll ich habe
ihren schrecken diese
schreckensnachrichten gelesen dass die
invasion kurz bevor stände wie ist denn
die lage vor ort wie ist deine
einschätzung
janina ich stehe hier in kiew
mittlerweile wieder vor der st sofia
kathedrale dort beten die menschen jeden
tag dass kein weiterer angriff kein noch
größerer kritieren der ukraine passiert
bin wieder in kiew gelandet vor genau
einer stunde und ich war zwei tage mit
dem ukrainischen präsidenten unterwegs
wenn man mit dem easy lenski unterwegs
ist dann spürt man zum einen die
anspannung wir waren heute an der front
mit ihm heute morgen hat es da ein
schläge gegeben und seelands gerhard
gesagt zu mir nein ich will da jetzt hin
und ich will zeigen dass ich nicht in
panik bin dass ich bereit bin hier zu
stehen und auch für mein land ein risiko
einzugehen also sind wir da über die
front gelaufen durch kaputte
zerschossene häuser und selensky hat
immer wieder zu mir gesagt das ist was
wir hier verteidigen müssen das ist
etwas was auch europa tun müsst und man
konnte ihm sehr sehr genau anmerken dass
er wütend darüber ist er hat es nicht so
gesagt denn er muss auch diplomat sein
in diesen stunden er findet immer noch
dass es zu wenig unterstützung aus
deutschland geht dass man nicht versteht
was die ängste der ukraine sind und
gleichzeitig den augen auf deine frage
zurückzukommen werden die warnungen
immer massiver von joe biden der gesagt
hat ist kann er jederzeit immer noch
passieren und das ist auch tatsächlich
etwas was immer mehr ukraine hier
besorgt auch wenn präsident gesagt bitte
behaltet die ruhe aber es ist
möglicherweise die ruhe vor dem sturm
und immer mehr glauben dass man
möglicherweise eine invasion doch nicht
verhindern kann
paul du hast auch heute also gerade
einen aktuellen bombenangriff gesehen
was ist da passiert
es gab mehrere angriffe heute zum einen
in lugano in der separatisten region und
dann heute morgen auf einen kindergarten
das ist mittlerweile bestätigt worden
und auch vor wenigen stunden so meldet
die polizei gab es erneut einschläge in
dieser region uns haben aktuelle bilder
erreicht es gibt die große sorge und das
ist auch das was von den usa immer
wieder gesagt wird dass eine volks fleck
mission starten könnte von russland dass
man versucht die ukraine so sehr zu
provozieren dass sie dann zurück
schlagen und dass putin dann eine chance
hätte zu sagen jetzt müssen wir
einmarschieren also große große sorgen
hier in kiew vor den nächsten stunden
vor den nächsten tagen
danke dir für deine einschätzung und wir
bleiben weiter du hast auch versprochen
wir bleiben weiter du bleibst vor ort
bild bleibt vor ort auch in den nächsten
wochen und monaten wir werden ja auch
bei 48 immer wieder natürlich auch in
die ukraine schauen danke paul danke
schön
wenn man das so hat herr bartsch was
geht ihnen durch den kopf gegangen wenn
sie hören wie es in der ukraine ist wie
sehen sie die lage stehen wir eine
inversion bevor man macht sich ja schon
angst als bürgerin ja selbstverständlich
ist eine hochgefährliche hochbrisante
lage ist völlig unbestritten allerdings
will ich auch nicht jede nachricht aus
den vereinigten staaten ganz ernst
nehmen denn am mittwoch war der krieg
schon also ich hab das ja mehrfach
gehört jetzt höre ich dass er
wiederkommt bin froh dass er nicht
gekommen dass ich finde jede
diplomatische regung vernünftiger als
dass geschossen wird und ich wünsche mir
dass die truppen konzentration abgebaut
wird aber ich muss brown wieder sprechen
dass die ukraine so furchtbar
demokratische und toller start ist das
teile ich auch stunden nicht usain ist
eines der korruptesten länder trotzdem
sage ich ganz klar ist jegliche invasion
völlig indiskutabel ist unbestritten
unbestritten deshalb ja obwohl es
optimal ulmer kromm ob joe biden jedes
gespräch ist richtig und wichtig und
perspektivisch ist meine these wir
brauchen ein system kollektiver
sicherheit in europa und der einschluss
russlands denn frieden in europa ist nur
mit russland und nicht gegen russland
durchsetzbares eine atommacht und
deswegen sind auch waffenlieferungen in
die ukraine völlig falsch was soll das
usa frankreich großbritannien haben
gesagt niemals würden sie militärisch
eingreifen ich denn da waffen hin
schicke das ist glaube ich wenig
sinnvoll griechen muss sich ergänzen
wenig begeistert davon dass nach dem
mann diplomatische
fäden wieder geknüpft hat und sich
verabredet hat die weiterzuverfolgen
jetzt heute auch die nato wieder
unterwegs war und in einem ton den ich
zu schaaf fand behauptet hat die russen
lügen der einmarsch kommt und alles was
ist da schon gehabt wird wieder
abgeschnitten hat das hat so geht das
nicht also eigentlich ist die zeit dass
die nato vielleicht ihnen die initiative
ergreifen müsste um wieder mal und eine
konferenz für sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa
zusammenzusuchen inklusive russland dass
alle staaten am tisch setzen und
überlegen wie sie miteinander ihr leben
organisiert jeder vermittler jede
vermittlerin ist gut ich habe ja nicht
nur uns die ehemalige kanzlerin
vorgeschlagen weekend putin gut die
kennzahlen ski gut das wäre vielleicht
die möglichkeit miteinander nur
miteinander wird man reden können und
ich glaube dass das eine wesentliche
voraussetzung wäre wenn du ukraine und
russland unter der schirmherrschaft von
frankreich und deutschland miteinander
reden ich glaube
gerade vor ich hätte diese ängste
bedenken hierüber wurden truppen
aufgebaut jetzt können sie in mein land
kommen ich denke da vor allem an die
menschen in dem start ich finde das ganz
durch mit allem was man von dort sieht
aus der ukraine jedenfalls aus kiew ist
es ja nicht so dass die menschen nun
jeden abend in die kathedrale gehen und
beten gegen den krieg sondern die sehen
das zum teil sehr kühl und realistisch
und sagen die kommen nicht wir sind ja
eine familie haben jan die luft war vor
ort und reste ja schon hätte aber
vielleicht hast du nach dem weg in sein
dass sie das nur interviews mit menschen
hier die sagen ach ja ich habe keine
angst gehen ihrem leben nach also so
ganz heiß ist die geschichte nicht
gottlob ja und man muss halt man muss
halt in der politik darauf achten dass
man jetzt nicht wieder alles zerschlägt
die zarten pflänzchens hat wird dies da
mal gegeben hat wir werden sobald paar
runs heimat zurück ist auf jeden fall
eine diskussionsrunde zwischen uli
engers und polens kann man so ukraine
machen
zuschauer jetzt gehen wir weiter und
denken trotzen an die menschen der
ukraine aber ich glaube da sind wir uns
alle einig bei dem thema und geben
weiterhin zu erwarten ja ich habe ein
ganz anderes thema mitgebracht aber
eines das glaube ich viele menschen in
unserem land sehr sehr bewegt das sind
die steigenden energiepreise die
explodierenden energiepreise deutschland
ist jetzt schon europameister bei diesen
preisen und die ampel tut viel zu wenig
das ganze ist eine entwicklung die über
jahre zugelassen worden ist aber es muss
endlich gehandelt werden denn für viele
menschen wird die energiekosten
abrechnung ein riesenproblem deswegen es
gibt viele vorschläge man kann schon so
nachbarn schauen in polen sind zum
beispiel ist die mehrwertsteuer
reduziert worden für energiekosten an
den tankstellen wäre für deutschland
zumindest zeitweise eine möglichkeit ja
es ist jetzt ein heizkostenzuschuss von
135 euro beschlossen worden aber ehrlich
gesagt wenn man die heime durch zwölf
teilt weiß man dass was das für die
einzelne familie bedeutet und auch die
permanent vor sich hergetragen eine
these die eeg-umlage wird hier
abgeschafft na hoffentlich ist noch
nicht in tüten und dann zum ersten
sieben aber die hälftige abschaffung zum
ersten ersten hat sehr wenig gebracht
also ganz klar hier muss die ampel
handeln denn im wahlkampf haben
sozialdemokraten freie demokraten und
grüne gesagt sie werden die bürger
entlasten so passiert schon beisteuern
faktisch nicht aber bei energie gibt es
eine gewaltige verteuerung und das geld
das geld ist eben da die
mehrwertsteuereinnahmen sind jetzt viel
höher als vor corona und da muss ein
teil beim bürger wieder ankommen
insbesondere bei denjenigen mit den
kleinen einkommen ich glaube diese
herausforderung ist auf längere zeit
eine der größten vor der wir in
deutschland stehen es muss endlich
gehandelt wird
awo herbert ich muss sagen ich bin ich
bin verblüfft und erfreut dass ich einem
der prominentesten politiker der linken
aus vollem herzen zustimmen kann und ich
glaube auch im nächsten satz würden sie
nicht zum spiel mehr die reichen werden
immer reicher die mittelklasse bricht
weg und der rest verarmt so das alles
wird angetrieben von einer ideologischen
klimapolitik die wie die vollkommen
gefühllos gegenüber dem dem ja der der
finanzlage und großer teile unserer
bevölkerung ist dass er okay ich wir
sind uns einig dass diese klimafrage
eine der größten herausforderung ist nur
wie man sie angehen das geht doch nur
mit den menschen und ich komme aus einer
region vorpommern vergleichsweise arm
aber vor allen dingen ist dort zum
beispiel das auto enorm wichtig weil die
leute ja es gibt keinen öffentlichen
personen- und nahverkehr
die alte ölheizung die ist nicht so ohne
weiteres zu ersetzen sind diese leute
haben richtig angst ich kenne das aus
vielen gesprächen und das müssen wir
ernst aber es ist keiner hier richtig
ein elitärer klimaschutz wird scheitern
wir müssen mit den menschen und zwar
weltweit dafür sorgen deswegen sind die
energiepreise so eine bedrohung weil die
steigerung der energiepreise wird die
akzeptanz für maßnahmen gegen den
klimawandel reduzieren und deswegen muss
gehandelt werden es sind unser aller
interesse
und deswegen verstehe ich auch nicht wie
man über alle möglichen dinge jetzt
nachdenken kann auch haushaltspolitisch
und dieses thema so wenig auf der agenda
hat dann christian linder dann sagt naja
also die eeg-umlage und wir haben ja
schon gehandelt nein wir haben nicht
gehandelt wann gibt es endlich das
konzept was ja angekündigt war dass die
leute was zurückerhalten und sie haben
also mutig wäre ich gar nicht gewesen
hier aber sie haben völlig recht wir
haben eine situation dass in der krise
diejenigen mit den riesenvermögen die
milliardäre haben ihr vermögen
vervielfacht das ist absurd und dann
haben wir mehr menschen in armut das
geht nicht wir müssen handeln und ich
glaube dass da eben das was die ampel
vereinbart hat wir machen letztlich auch
steuerpolitisch im gebiet faktisch nicht
da dass die realität im einkommensteuer
bereich gar nichts kapital überall
nichts der vortrag den kristallen dazu
halt den kenne ich da ist auch insoweit
in ordnung wir haben im wahlkampf häufig
gestritten aber all die versprechen aus
dem wahlkampf und zwar von allen
leistungen gesprochen von einer halle
haben von der islamischen woche und es
ist gerade das gegenteil ist der fall so
dass filme insofern zu diese koalition
hat schlecht angefangen ich habe sie für
mich mal die stümper koalition genannt
haben gesehen dass die dass der
wirtschafts und klimaminister habeck in
die bauindustrie ihre eingeschlagen hat
dass die leute gar nicht wussten wie sie
ihre häuser weiter bauen sollen der
vielen wer sollten überhaupt noch heute
haben wir hier loben sich der januar war
eine der schlimmsten tage wo an einem
tag entschieden worden ist förderung ist
jetzt schluss so ist war für
energetische sanierung gehäuse lagen
milliarden anträge wo es auch von
menschen die wenig haben und die darauf
gesetzt habe ich glaube ganz schlimm ich
kann ob er wie wichtig ist viel zu wenig
wichtig ist die idee in ihrem vortrag
ist die mehrwertsteuersenkung und zwar
nicht nur auf energie sondern es wird ja
alles teurer das wird alle alle alle
basismaterialien metall holz alles war
auch lebens mit auch lebensmittel und
insofern ist mit ist die zeit gekommen
darüber eine breite diskussion zu finden
ich wollte es in fragen wie stellen sie
sich jetzt mal quantitativ die manager
senkung vor auf welches niveau runter
gehen na ja gut das ist wir haben ja in
deutschland mehrwertsteuersätze und da
sind die sieben prozent wären eben genau
das richtige dass man ermäßigten
mehrwertsteuersatz mindestens zeitweise
ob man das dauerhaft aufträge auf
energie ja selbstverständlich und wir
haben den energiesteuern und das zweite
wo sich alles ist unsozial steuert das
sind mehrwertsteuer erst einmal das
zweite was ich sage ist der anteil der
steueranteil auch bei energie auch bei
anderen darf nicht über 50 prozent sein
er ist teilweise über 50 prozent das ist
doch absurd da wird klar natürlich die
konzerne verdienen teilweise immer noch
unendliches geld auch da kann und muss
man etwas tun gar keine frage man kann
auch diese zuschüsse machen aber der
kern ist dass wir dort wirklich in einer
an in ein anderes system müssen im
übrigen das trifft auch lebensmittel das
dürfen wir auch nicht unterschätzen sagt
wir haben die inflation also wir haben
wir sind nicht in einer das ist jetzt
nicht das ist der neuen regierung nicht
anzulasten das hat sie vielfach geerbt
da es lange zeit viel zu wenig gehandelt
worden ist auch ein europäisches ein
weltweites problem im übrigen hat das
mit der ukraine zu tun von wegen
energiekosten wir beziehen 55 prozent
unseres erdgases aus russland wenn wir
da sehr schlaue reden nur zwei hättet
ist nicht in betrieb da ändert sich
erstmal gar nichts aber nur auf 71 gibt
und es gibt die anderen und wenn dort
nichts mehr fließt dann haben ein
problem die amerikaner sind da ganz
anders die haben ihre erdölimporte aus
russland gesteigert den letzten monaten
ich finde das normal wetter erwähnt wie
willich und höhere in deutschland wir
sind da wieder die vorreiter aber die
anderen sehen das sehr unruhig aber das
hat mit energiepreisen zu tun die viel
zum thema zurückkommen das entscheidende
ist wenn er doch offen für maßnahmen die
mehrwertsteuerabsenkung ist ein punkt
den einmalzuschuss ist ein punkt es gibt
viele weitere die man wirklich also
natürlich erneuerbare energien kann
alles eine rolle spielen aber nicht
handeln und zu sagen die eeg-umlage und
ihre abdeckung zum ersten julio der
streichung zum ersten juli löst unser
problem das wird nicht ausreicht sie
haben vorhin gesagt sie hätten das schon
mehrfach artikuliert was sie haben hier
auch gesagt haben haben sie das im
bundestag schon mal vorgetragen und wie
war die reaktion bei den anderen
parteien ich habe das im bundestag
vorgetragen das interessante ist ja dass
das jetzt nicht nur irgendwie ein
solitär vorschlag ist also der bekannte
ökonom bofinger sagt auch das ist eine
möglichkeit wäre die gewerkschaft
unterstützt hat es gibt also nicht
wenige und ich sag nochmal nachbarländer
tun ist einfach sie tun es einfach und
wir machen an dieser stelle nichts weiß
ich das im moment vieles noch ein
haushaltsberatung liegt und dass wir
riesige aufgaben haben aber ich glaube
das thema energiepreise wird uns die
nächsten wochen monate und jahre bewegen
das wird das zentrale thema in den
nächsten jahren sein hoffe ich
jedenfalls nicht das ist ein krieg das
war doch ein schönes schlussplädoyer die
these von herbert und wir gehen weiter
zu unserem kolumnisten alexander von
stimmung und hier darf ich mal ein
bisschen eigenwerbung für bild machen
auf der letzten seite gibt es immer
seine klumpe damit starte ich meinen tag
denkt auch mal lesen
ja das stimmt mit dem stimme ich
natürlich zu aber sich heute fordern
werde ist ein volksaufstand gegen google
amazon facebook und co wir reden alle
vom künftigen klimakollaps und sonstigen
gefahren die in ferner zukunft liegen
und schauen daran vorbei dass wir längst
opfer einer ktm keiner katastrophe sind
die jetzt im moment stattfindet
und die nicht in ferner zukunft
stattfindet sondern hier und jetzt sie
sind opfer der sogenannten surveillance
economy einer neuen wirtschaftsordnung
die darauf hinausläuft die darauf
basiert uns auszuleuchten uns
auszuspionieren und und süchtig zu
machen facebooks mutterkonzern meter hat
noch nicht
angekündigt dass sie damit mit dem
gedanken spielen sich aus europa
zurückzuziehen
das klang für mich unter der grund war
dass die datenschutz vorgaben der eu zu
streng sein für mich ist die wahrung von
facebook und instagram sich aus europa
zurück zu ziehen etwa so bedrohlich als
ob das
sinaloa-kartell in mexiko damit droht
sich aus dem europa als lou kokain
geschäft in europa zurückzuziehen ich
fordere dass wir endlich aufwachen
hier läuft gründlich was schief diese
konzerne sind viel zu mächtig sie
spionieren uns aussieht verdienen
verdienen ihr geld mit unseren daten und
wir haben jetzt diese digitale
revolution geht jetzt erst seit 20
jahren ist auch relativ normal dass man
es später dahinter kommt was für macht
er was für macht dort gewalt ist und ich
hoffe auf feste unterstützung von herrn
bartsch auch riesig diese konzerne zu
zerschlagen oder zumindest so stark zu
reglementieren dass wir dem einen stopp
setzen denn das ist eine gefahr die
jetzt aktuell stattfindet und nicht
irgendwie ferner zu tun
solche media gerade denke ich als junge
junge leute aber es nutzt ja immer mehr
ältere auch wenn ich nur auf facebook
sehen nicht nur die natur sich jetzt
also es ist so essenziell für politische
kommunikation
[Gelächter]
wenn es wer schaut heutzutage doch auf
eine homepage ja es läuft alles über
facebook instagram wie man sich
repräsentiert öffentlichkeitsarbeit und
da ist natürlich dann die frage ist
nicht so weit fortgeschritten dass wir
davon tatsächlich abhängig sind also
genau die these raimund wie wir es genau
das ist die frage ich denke in einigen
als wir können uns
umwandeln mit dann auf andere wenn jetzt
facebook nicht mehr in europa wäre
finden wir andere möglichkeiten das ist
keine frage nur die frage ist wie sehr
sind wir abhängig und wollen überhaupt
dass facebook beispielsweise die vorgabe
ist wieder die fahrt durch ist eine
sache das natürlich natürlich noch mal
zum vergleich zu dem mediziner
sinaloa-kartell zurückzukommen natürlich
sind die big tech konzerne keine
verbrecherorganisationen aber was man
nicht oft genug wiederholen kann weil
das wenige leute wissen bei der
entstehung war der entwicklung von apps
wie instagram oder tik tok wurden
neurowissenschaftler in die in die
entwicklung mit einbezogen mit dem
gezielten mit den gezielten absicht die
app so zu entwickeln dass sie süchtig
machen indem sie unser doppelhaushalt im
im gehirn
manipulieren und ich möchte den
vergleich zum bezug kokain tatsächlich
noch mal ernsthaft wiederholen als wo
als vor 100 jahren kokain auf den markt
kam dann bekam er das freien apotheken
hat das zum teil gegen hornhaut
beschwerden und gegen heuschnupfen
eingesetzt erst später ist man dann
dahinter gekommen dass es eben süchtig
macht wir sind jetzt an einem zeitpunkt
dass wir sehen dass diese das nicht nur
diese konzerne unglaublich
räuberisch mit unseren daten umgehen
sondern dass sie gezielt von anfang an
so konzipiert waren dass die junge leute
süchtig machen ich war neulich in einer
ausstellung von einem fall von einem
fotografen harald hauswald dem sie
wahrscheinlich kennen er war der gründer
von ostkreuz da hat mich ich bin fast
sicher ich habe das gemacht so fotos aus
berlin der 80er jahre im
und was man dort sieht kinder die auf
der straße spielen der eine hat ein
holzschwert in der an der anhalten
kaputtes fahrrad das sieht man heute gar
nicht mehr ich bin mit meinem sohn am
strand entlang gegangen big mich rum der
hat ihn so erwischt dann musste er
selber lachen wir schaffen natürlich
macht das süchtig und geber kokain wo
man auch erst 20 30 40 jahre darauf
reagiert hat müssen wir diese gefahr
jetzt langsam ernst nehmen der wachs ist
wächst eine generation heran die gar
nicht netten die ein autor das neulich
geschrieben es ist so als ob beständig
mit juckpulver bestreut werden das
müssen wir endlich ernst nehmen und ich
fordere euch auf handys dabei eine app
eurer wahl musste abend zu löschen
twitter an wer jetzt heute abend also
hätten oder instagram und ich werde ich
erst noch snap chat also eigentlich eh
nicht so schnell die leute sie löschen
snap etwas tun was sie denn alle social
media also erweitert es läuft
großes problem ist ich mache ja und so
alles ganze und alle zuschauer auch weil
sie will sich jetzt eine app aus und
löst eine app wie instagram ich habe
bist du sicher dass du sie löschen das
ding ist die passion der account bleibt
ja bestehen wenn man sicher ist schon
mal gut aber du musst dich jetzt wieder
einmal ein loch oder so weiter aber was
ich stoße ich will dich zu ich wollte
nur zwei bemerkungen dazu man erstens
bei kindern hält man diese entwicklung
nicht auf also die sind ja schon bevor
sie in die schule kommen affin mit dem
rest doch eine kapitulation sind ja
weiter hält man das über antworten die
das keine kapitulation dass eine
gesellschaft ist anders geworden auch
die kommunikation ist anders geworden
die lesen keine zeitungen mehr die
werden nie eine zeitung lesen und auch
keine zeitschrift die zeiten sind vorbei
die gehen alle kaputt sie sind man sagen
aber ich glaube dass man erst wenn man
relativ erwachsen ist die größe im kopf
hat zu entscheiden was man da nicht tut
und dann zu entscheiden wo man rausgeht
und wo man drinnen bleibt und das ist
ich bin zum beispiel niemals bei
facebook mitglied geworden ich habe die
frauen eingeschrieben raus aus facebook
habe ich immer für gefährlich gehalten
da bin ich noch gesteinigt worden ich
brauche facebook nicht für nichts
braucht doch sonst niemand und es hat
lange gedauert bis herr beck und frau
merkel bei facebook ausgetreten sind
weil sie dann zu langsam erkannt haben
was das eigentlich für ein laden ist
facebook hat aber glaube ich seine hohe
zeit hinter sich da sinken inzwischen
wieder die abonnentenzahlen und es gibt
eine aber diese gegend kam er ans
gegeben es gibt
weil die 20-jährigen auf instagram und
die
sagen das auch schon mal so rog hat es
wird die leute die auf facebook
zugreifen
die sind in dem alter über 40 geht es
los in zug hat ihre starke ausbreitung
15 noch älter so richtig ist instagram
ist tik tok das sind die nummern und da
haben sie ja völlig recht ich meine ich
bin ja sehr dafür die konzerne zu
zerschlagen nur das schaffen wir beide
nicht aber die liebe wieder zu haben was
wir können was wir können und das ist
doch der rockefeller hat auch geklappt
wie wir dann schlage jeder kann etwas
tun natürlich ist das erstens süchtig
machen das auszusprechen sagen was ist
es auszuscheiden auszusprechen menschen
zu warnen und dann wird sich auch diese
erkenntnis natürlich verbreitern und
fest in der verständlichen zerschlagen
werden wie sie nicht das sind
ausgeklügelte mechanismen denen wir im
übrigen auch alle zum opfer fallen und
in der politik im übrigen ist es ja so
da gibt es ja fast eine verpflichtung
das zu machen wer auf keinem netzwerk
ist wie will ich mal sehen also ich
misstraue eilig von metternich frau ein
die zu viert dann wären mehr als einmal
antritt
was haben sie denn gewählt
das geht ja das sensor
[Gelächter]
noch nicht
nein aber ich ein ganz ganz wesentlicher
punkt wo man laut sagen muss was es
bedeutet und alle ja auch die großen
verlage es ist ja nicht so dass die
jetzt nicht bei twitter bei facebook bei
all diesen neuen plattformen sind
natürlich natürlich rang 1 punkt einig
dass an der stelle sagen kann meine
kolumne erscheint ausschließlich in
print und ich halte auch print uns durch
schon weil ich möchte nicht ich möchte
ich mal meine kolumne ist gemacht fürs
papier wenn es immer das allerletzte was
im bild erscheinen und das funktioniert
er im internet gar nicht es gibt ja im
internet nicht das letzte buch hat sie
immer weiter scrollen das heißt bei
erscheint nur exklusive rind und ich
muss sagen ich halte auch diese ständige
gerede bringt ist vorbei und das ist das
andere ist die zukunft ich glaube dass
das teil eines augen
sehen physische bibliothek zu wort
humanen kontakt zu machen und nicht
alles ständig über suchen sich
irgendwelche datei löschen das ist das
lernen was miteinander reden miteinander
quatschen und mich alles überwiegen das
ist ja ich will nur einen vorschlag
machen von meena wieder abwinkt und mir
das wort ab 31 also ich glaube das schon
lange auffällig ist das war an den
schulen medien unterricht fachrichtung
überall wo die jungen leute aufgeklärt
werden darüber was sich in den so
wichtigen werken
waren sind womit sie ihr geld verdienen
und es
steht so nicht braucht es macht süchtig
ich möchte dass bei instagram und bei
tecdoc vorher steht es ist süchtig und
dass die tasten ist gesteht gespräche
dass das die politiker auch wenn sie uns
ständig angst machen vor
irgendwelchen von irgendwelchen
erkrankungen die immer harmloser werden
dass sie auch mal die angst vor die
angst vor der tat digitaler
verwahrlosung ernst genommen würden dass
es ein thema ist über das öffentlich
diskutiert wird und nicht einfach gesagt
das muss man einfach so hinnehmen das
könnten hätte man bei kokain auch seine
leider schon zu ende gekommen schmeckte
mit dem schönsten satz heute schließen
wir haben die generalprobe der
demokratie nicht bestanden das war mein
lieblingssatz heute abend wir sehen uns
dienstagabend wieder schön abend noch
und danke dass sie dabei waren tschüss
[Musik]